In news that I am sure will come as a shock
to absolutely no one who's been [inaudible]
paying attention.
The Senate is set to acquit Donald Trump in
his impeachment trial.
By the time you listen to today's show, by
the time you watch this segment, it may already
have happened.
It may be soon to happen.
It may be a happening tomorrow.
Now, let me do something here.
If you've not been following the situation
in the Senate and I actually over the weekend,
I talked to some friends who said, I haven't
seen anything.
I said, you're better off.
Quite frankly, you might wonder, why is it
not shocking that Trump is going to be found
not guilty in his impeachment trial?
Well, if you've not been following the trial,
you might think that this is a trial, like
a normal trial where the the jurors, the 100
senators in the Senate will come in with an
open mind.
They will hear the evidence, they will welcome
evidence and then they will evaluate the facts
to decide whether an impeachment conviction
of Donald Trump makes sense or otherwise,
whether an acquittal of Donald Trump makes
sense.
That's what you might think if you had not
been paying attention at all, in which case
I envy you, but that's not the situation we
have.
We knew in advance that because there are
53 Republican senators in the Senate and you
need 67 senators to vote to convict in order
to get a conviction in an impeachment trial
in the Senate, Republicans had made it clear
they plan to acquit in advance.
We knew that Trump was going to be found not
guilty no matter what happened.
Now, unfortunately, it's even worse because
it's not just that Republican senators decided
in advance that they were going to equip Donald
Trump, but they went through and at least
pretended to be handling this like a normal
trial.
It's worse than that.
Republicans voted on Friday not to even hear
from witnesses firsthand witnesses while claiming
for months.
The problem is we don't have any firsthand
witnesses here.
And this is why the term cover up is increasingly
being used to describe, describe what is a
sham impeachment trial.
Now Republicans have been using the term sham,
not a sham, like a sham.
Wow.
The type you would use, you know, a terrycloth,
uh, a dish towel that you would use to clean
things.
They've been using the term sham to describe
the mere fact that Donald Trump was impeached
by the house.
And of course it's often projection.
There was a sham here, but the sham was that
this was anything like a real trial.
And in a way, I know I've said before and
a lot of people don't like when I say this,
that Mitch McConnell has been an extremely
asset to Republicans and one of the most effective
Republican, uh, tools.
And I say that not, not in, in the, um, a
pejorative way, but a very useful tool to
Republicans.
You've got to hand it to them.
Republicans have played this really, really
well at the start of the trial, Democrats
wanted to decide, are we going to have witnesses?
Are we going to have documents?
Are we going to issue subpoenas?
And Republicans said, let's figure that out
later.
Of course Republicans had the majority, so
they got it.
Republicans successfully said, let's do 64
hours of trial.
First, 24 hours of house, impeachment managers,
24 hours of Trump's attorneys, 16 hours of
Senator questions.
Let's do all of that first and then we will
decide about witnesses and every time that
Democrats stood up and said, I have an amendment
for the proceedings where we will decide now
about witnesses.
Republican said, we already have a plan for
that.
We're going to do that after 64 hours of proceedings
in any other trial, it would not have been
done this way.
In any other trial, you decide first about
witnesses and evidence so that both sides
can build their cases around the witnesses
and the documents.
That would be part of the trial, but Republicans
control the Senate and they got their way.
And then we saw last week, we talked about
this during my live streams as the 64 hours
of proceedings, we're starting to reach the
end.
Republicans started to slip in this line that
we noticed, which is once we're done with
these 64 hours, we'll decide whether we really
need to hear more, and this is evil genius
because they started making it about have
we had enough hours of trial when really the
issue is not, do we need 64 or 84 104 hours
of trial?
The issue is, are there material firsthand
witnesses who could testify and the answer
is yes.
Former national security advisor, John Bolton,
remember Republican said, nobody here is a
firsthand witness.
It was a lie.
Binman was a firsthand witness.
We had others, but John Bolton would unquestionably
be a firsthand witness.
They don't want them.
Bolton saying in his upcoming book and likely
would say the same thing under oath, which
is Donald Trump personally told me, hold the
aid to Ukraine until they publicly smear Joe
Biden.
That's a firsthand witness.
They don't want it.
Rudy's henchman love Parness.
He has recordings.
He is not.
We have a, by the way, a second video in which
he is meeting with Donald Trump.
He was putting physical surveillance on ambassador
Maria Vonnegut.
She's a firsthand participant.
Now we don't need to hear him.
Republicans say the acquittal means nothing,
but it also means everything to the people
who just want to be let off the hook so they
can vote for Trump in November of 2020.
If you complain about no firsthand witnesses
and simultaneously blocked firsthand witnesses,
you are not an honest actor.
You are not a good faith participant.
So let's just cut to the end of the story
because I think most of you know where this
is going.
As I've said on the show since is April of
2017, the Mueller probe was never going to
remove Donald Trump, the 25th amendment.
No matter how bad Trump gets, cognitively
will not be used to remove Donald Trump impeachment
or impingement as some of our, our, um, uh,
angry right-wing email or say impeachment
was never going to remove Donald Trump.
Are you going to remove Donald Trump?
Is the question because the, the single and
solitary way to do it is to vote in such overwhelming
numbers in November that even, uh, election
tampering, even foreign interference, even
voter purges as it had been happening in a
number of different States, won't be enough
to get them reelected.
I agree with you that the way this has gone
is disgusting and it's not really a trial,
but at a certain point we've got to play the
hand that's dealt in the game that everybody
else is playing as opposed to insisting we'd
rather be playing a different game or have
a different hand.
And that's the last option we have.
The question in terms of the repercussions
of the impeachment acquittal is now the one
that I've been suggesting for several weeks
or months.
Is the acquittal going to reinvigorate Trump's
supporters who will feel that Trump has been
vindicated instead of just being the beneficiary
of a sham trial?
Mitch McConnell grinning ear to ear and we
knew he would be always proved something bad
happened if Mitch McConnell was happy, happy.
By the way, Trump is tweeting vindication
and attacks on Democrats, but there has been
no vindication.
His followers will believe there was one and
so we have to do this thing and it starts
today.
It starts today with the Iowa caucuses because
you can bet your ass that the next cover up
is going to be much worse because there are
no consequences.
Some people went to prison because of the
Mueller probe.
Yes, love Parness and Igor Fruman.
We don't know what's going to happen to them,
but in context compared to what they've gotten
away with, there have really been no consequences.
The only countervailing force here is such
a crushingly massive defeat in November that
they can't use their dirty tricks of voter
suppression, foreign interference, election
tampering, all that stuff that they won't
be able to use that to win and otherwise it's
over folks.
I mean we just have to recognize it's another
four years of this with all of the garbage
that comes with it.
Hillary Clinton now is saying things publicly
that are only going to help Donald Trump,
which we're going to talk about a little bit
later.
It's a mess.
So let's take step one.
A journey of a thousand miles begins with
one step.
Feel like it's very a very uh, prescient,
um, a proverb in the context of the Trump
administration.
Let's take step one tonight in Iowa.
Go and participate.
Let's have a clean caucus.
We'll have live coverage on YouTube, Twitch,
and Facebook tonight as the results come in.
Join me.
And then tomorrow we will take step two.